Rainbow six experts in close quarters  battle and hostage-rescue  assembled from Special Forces teams  around the world  the counterterrorism units we've run ups  in 47 countries when the job still  teachers for everyone else we go in the  regiment's been active since World War  two  she'll knew even existed we pull the  best for the Army Navy and Air Force  only a handful make it through training  to make the regiment you need strength  skill and determination but more than  anything you need character means on our  path presence atop data we get from  above the adrenaline explodes your own  body you need to control it focus it  time stretches and you get really calm  you feel ready ready  Turkey's combine top down infant toxic  gas an overwhelming speed we eat for the  skill combined Alicia  it's what you do  you